[Music]
welcome back I'm joined by the author
and Associated of The Spectator Douglas
Murray well Douglas you'd be waiting
patiently over there in Israel uh what
did you make of that extraordinary
interview um well I mean um listening to
Jeremy Corgan let alone Len uh talking
about the Middle East and the way to
solve the middle east's problems is like
watching somebody trying to do brain
surgery whilst wearing boxing gloves I
mean it is so cack-handed it's just
beyond
belief nobody in this region could make
any sense of their dreams and claims and
assertions it it it everything that they
said falls apart on first analysis and
the most extraordinary thing to me was
Jeremy Corbin's Resolute refusal to
answer two simple questions should Hamas
stay in power and are they a terror
group he wouldn't do it let mclusky
answered both but Corbin was paralyzed
he he could not answer those two basic
questions but I'm afraid as you know uh
appear That's a character career trait
of Jeremy Corbin's it was just the same
with Shin Fay
Ira uh he always seems to keep the door
open to Terror groups whether they are
anti-british Terror groups like the IRA
or anti-israel groups like Hamas I don't
know why he feels this need he's never
been involved in any International Peace
negotiations any anywhere certainly
never anywhere with any success never
anywhere with any prominence even so
it's always bizarre to hear him talking
as if he's sort of been the UN Secretary
General for the last 50 years and quite
scary to think he was nearly potentially
prime minister of this country I mean it
does beggar the question if this had
happened to us what would his reaction
have been if he's not able to say that
Hamas after what they did on October the
7th or a terrorist organization what
would have happened if a terror
organization had killed 1500 British
people on our soil if he'd been running
the
country absolutely and I and I'd add to
that I mean you know he talks about the
the importance of clarity and and being
absolutely clear on things and is very
unclear on things himself what he just
said there about the Palestinians and
Hamas and I mean they he and Len mcasi
talk about Palestine for instance what
do they mean by Palestine do they mean
the West Bank do they mean the West Bank
and Gaza do they mean the West Bank Gaza
and East Jerusalem like what is this
state do they mean everything in
pre-1948 or post 1948 they never say
they just talk about this non-existent
state that still doesn't exist because
for decade after decade people like them
have supported the worst possible
elements and have encouraged them in
this delusion that Israel can be
disappeared it's not going to be
disappeared and yet this delusion is
encouraged among other things among some
people in the Palestinian leadership
which is why when they're offered 19 9%
of a state as they have been time and
time again they say no because 99% isn't
100% well that clip I found of Bill
Clinton from a few years ago was very
telling both in his description of what
Hamas do which they're now doing uh and
also in the fact that he had a a great
settlement there and Arafat at the last
minute screwed him just walked
away absolutely Arafat walked away as it
as his predecessors had walked away time
and again uh it could all be so
different you know it could all be so
different just going back to what's
happened in Gaza since the withdrawal
you know remember the Israelis left Gaza
in 2005 it was extremely traumatic for
the people of Israel because they saw
members of their own Army pulling
forcibly Jewish families from their
homes because they said that they would
give Gaza over to the Palestinians there
were elections Hamas won the elections
killed their fat Rivals and then never
had another election how can anyone
defend this group or believe they're a
legitimate government of Palestine and
the idea that there any part I tell you
one thing Piers it's very very obvious
when you're here in the in the period
after the massacres of October the 7th
it doesn't matter whether you're
right-wing or leftwing it doesn't matter
whether you're a pnic like many of the
people who are murdered in the kots or
um a supporter of Benjamin Netanyahu
nobody in Israel believes that they can
live beside Hamas nobody no well why
would you I mean Hamas are dedicated in
their Charter to the eradication of
Israel and they've proven on October the
7th they will kill as many Jewish people
as they can get their hands on and the
Hamas spokesman only last week said they
want to do what happened October the 7th
again and again and again you can't do
peace with people with that mentality I
I
was I was at one of the trauma hospitals
earlier speaking to some survivors of
the the October attacks I was very
struck by one man in his I suppose 40s
50s um he and his family hid in their
safe room but they didn't lock safe
rooms they couldn't lock because they
were for bombs not for Hamas terrorists
coming door to door um his daughter
managed to survive he lost both his legs
um he lost his wife died in front of him
and his daughter and he lost his
14-year-old son and after this man
described what happened when his boy
breathed his last um he said look I'm a
leftist I've always been a leftist
Douglas just hold Doug hold your we're
just going to come off there on the show
but we're going to carry on this for our
YouTube so one second just stay with me
uh keep it un sensitive we're going to
keep with Douglas Murray we're going to
be live on our YouTube channel now keep
following I'll come back to
Douglas so just finish that anecdote you
met this guy and he was on the left you
said yes I mean you hear that all the
time one of the things that I think many
people outside Israel haven't realized
is that many of the k
the the the the places where people were
living The Villages and towns
neighboring Gaza were were filled with
leftwing pnik types the sort of people
for instance who um there was a woman in
wank kibuts who every you know every day
she drove Palestinian children to
hospitals um there were people who made
sure they always had uh Palestinian
colleagues from Gaza uh they would
employ them uh there even the peace uh
grave and near the borders of Gaza you
know was significantly populated by
people who sort of had had the peace uh
uh gig I mean that that was their belief
that was their view that they wanted to
live in peace with their Palestinian
neighbors I think that one thing that
people outside Israel really haven't
understood is that it is these people
who were disproportionately murdered in
their homes on October the 7th you know
you can see it literally on their on the
signs they have on their fridges and
their fridge doors in what remains of of
their houses um you know peace signs uh
um calls for peace um I think that this
is so important to realize and one other
thing many of the Hamas Fighters
terrorists who were who were found dead
or or captured alive uh after that day
were found to have plans on them which
had extraordinarily detailed uh um
issues about who lived in which house
there are stories of there's one kibuts
where the the man who was in charge of
security in the kibuts the terrorists
went to his house first and killed him
and his family and then went door too
elsewhere how did they have all of this
knowledge literally family by Family
door too it was because some of the
people they had given their trust to had
sold them out had given information over
to hamaz to get them killed
now that is going to have in Israel a
seismic effect in the years ahead anyone
who thinks that what we heard from
Jeremy Corbin and Len mcclusky is
remotely possible is living in a
different Century to the one we're now
in yeah I just don't think there's a cat
and hell's chance of Israel even
countenancing doing any kind of peace
deal with Hamas because Hamas are wedded
to violence and the eradication of
Israel and the Jewish people I me
they've made it blatantly clear it's not
something they
hide they've always made it blatantly
clear they've always made it clear in
their actions uh you know and and we
just all have to take this seriously
ourselves you know uh Israel takes it
seriously some people maybe some people
like the pnic I just described didn't
think they really meant it and and and
learned you know in the worst way
possible that they did but we have hamz
people in the UK we have hamz leaders in
the UK we've given Sanctuary to we
should all also realize these people
mean it peers you know and that if they
had the upper hand if they had their way
in the UK they wouldn't hesitate to do
the same thing that their friends did in
Israel last month yeah it's so true
Douglas Murray thank you very much
indeed for hanging on there I appreciate
it it's a pleasure have a good night
thank
you